[Music]
on this Sunday night nuke open 19 cases
in Canada connected to a cruise ship
tracing the moves of travelers exposed
to the new coronavirus anyone they've
been in contact with is going to be
personally contacted plus the demands on
the Canadian government to buffer the
impact on the economy we do need to be
prepared and we are preparing italy's
locked down mass hysteria at this point
a Canadian woman describes the chaos in
one of the worst outbreak zones plus
Bernie Sanders uncertain pop - the
Democratic nomination
[Music]
and the Canadian Catholic putting his
face in tik-tok
[Music]
global national with Robin Gil
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin with breaking news the
Canadian government has a plane ready to
bring home the 237 Canadians trapped on
the Grand Princess that's the cruise
ship off the coast of California the
request was made by the US government
those passengers will be screened before
boarding the plane and then be taken to
the Canadian Forces Base in Trenton
Ontario where they'll undergo 14 days of
isolation Global News broke the latest
developments to one of the Canadian
passengers on that cruise ship it feels
bloody wonderful look how it feels I
would rather be on Canadian soil under
Canadian medical care if that's
necessary then here in the United States
so I am exhilarated by that news here at
home the number of new cases keeps
climbing by the day today there are at
least 59 confirmed cases across the
country Alberta has its first confirmed
case as well as three presumptive cases
all of them are connected to travel
health officials in the province are
tracking their movements and the people
they may have been in close contact with
since becoming exposed to the new
coronavirus this marks four cases in
four days for many this may be alarming
I want to underline that three of these
four cases are linked to a single cruise
ship to be clear those cases are linked
to a previous voyage on the Grand
Princess but on this trip 21 people on
the ship have the new corona virus as
Jennifer Johnson reports the u.s. is
racing to limit the spread across the
country but health officials aren't
seeing eye-to-eye with the White House
on how to handle the outbreak the u.s.
is now seeing an acceleration of Kovan
19 cases as the disease spreads east
over 30 states reporting even the
District of Columbia its first patient a
church rector while the White House
continues to say it has the crisis under
control the nation's top infectious
disease doctor is telling a different
story
we certainly now that we have tests out
and get a better handle but clearly I'm
concerned about community spread you
have to realistically be concerned about
community spread dr. foe Qi is
encouraging vulnerable people to avoid
large gatherings
and avoid flying if they can the Trump
administration is denying reports it
overruled health officials who wanted
air travel restricted for this sick and
elderly calling the report complete
fiction
it's also downplaying concerns after a
person attending the CPAC conference
with President Donald Trump and vice
president Mike Pence last weekend in
Maryland tested positive for kovat 19
that's why we asked people to sanitize
their hands and to take various types of
precautions so the president does that
now some good news for over 3,500 people
including 237 Canadians stranded onboard
the Grand Princess off the coast of
California the ship will be allowed to
dock at the Port of Oakland likely on
Monday at least 21 people are infected
and will be hospitalized the others will
be taken to federal isolation sites to
be tested and quarantined for 14 days
New York's governor also looking to
protect his citizens a state of
emergency has been declared affecting
America's busiest tourist City we are
trying to contain the spread of the
virus how do you contain the spread of
the virus by testing as many people as
you can find the positives and then
isolate the positive people
government officials now say they are
producing more test kits which so far
couldn't keep up a demand the US Surgeon
General says it's working with private
industries and predicts there will be
about 4 million test kits available by
the end of the week Robin Jennifer
Johnson in Washington the worldwide
economy is taking massive hits from this
disease the International Air Transport
Association predicts global airlines
alone could lose up to 113 billion
dollars in sales here at home there
could also be major economic impacts
Michael Couture now on what the federal
government can do ahead of this spring's
budget
good afternoon Columbus travel it's not
something you hear very often these days
at Angela main our DS travel agency the
phone hasn't been ringing as fears of
covet 19 and the actual virus spread
this will be the straw that broke the
camel's back I mean this year if this
continues on inevitably there are people
who can't survive through this global
tourism will take a hit if kovat 19
can't be contained it's bad news for
Canada's tourism industry which is worth
about a hundred and two billion dollars
according to the tourism industry
Association of Canada a chunk of that
loss will be in cruise ships the Port of
Vancouver is a hub but Saturday B sees
health minister issued a strong warning
against traveling on cruise ships and
cruise companies are being forced to
adjust a book with confidence a program
so if you do book today and you're
unsure for whatever reason you can make
an adjustment because things are
changing day to day so other sectors may
not be as flexible and those are top of
mind for the finance minister as he
continues to craft a federal budget
which may include financial help for
those affected by Co vid 19 you know we
have a strong fiscal position so we're
prepared in terms of the actual health
risks but we have a strong position
fiscally so that we can actually take
measures as needed as the facts come out
but the Conservatives disagrees saying
by running up large deficits in their
first mandate the Liberal government is
not prepared to deal with the new
coronavirus or the rail blockades they
eliminated the cushion long ago and
they've put us in a place of weakness
and vulnerability as we face these two
crises
Morneau contends Canada is in a good
position pointing to the more than
30,000 jobs that were added to the
economy in February but in an interview
on the West block with Mercedes
Stevenson this senior economist at TD
Bank says the Finance Minister is taking
a narrow view of things they take a
broader picture we had a very soft end
to last year business investment you
know just really failing
deliver for several years now and you
have other interruptions rail blockades
weather things like that you know we're
talking about you know really not a lot
of growth growth buffer as we move into
the year expect that to be a central
theme when provincial and territorial
leaders meet with the federal government
at the end of next week in Ottawa it's
an opportunity for all levels of
government to discuss the response to
kovat 19 so far and the next steps as
the outbreak widens Robin Mike look at
or in Ottawa Italy's government has
imposed strict quarantine measures on a
quarter of the population to slow the
spread of copán 19 tonight 14 provinces
have been isolated mainly in Italy's
north the whole of Lombardy its
financial capital Milan and tourist hubs
like Modena and Venice all have travel
bans the 16 million people stuck there
can't get out and no one can come in 366
people have died in Italy infections are
spiking and the lockdown is sparking
widespread panic thousands tried to flee
South to escape being isolated Mike
drily spoke to a Canadian woman living
in Italy about the confusion and the
chaos on any given day this Venice
Piazza would be packed the cafes
bustling and Grand Canal overflowing
with tourists instead it stood as a
stark example of how hard Kovan 19 has
hit Italy my yo P vehicle he's gonna be
keen Sunday morning for the first time
ever Pope Francis delivered his Sunday
prayer via videolink
he admitted to feeling caged as he
looked out the window to a crowd of a
sparse few hundred where normally
thousands congregate I think the corona
meters is an exaggeration so I don't
think I think that overdoing it so he
should come out like it does every
Sunday frustration abounds
but Italy has seen more covet 19 cases
than any other country in Europe it's
strain has now been traced to a car
parts manufacturer in Germany and after
weeks of trying to contain the virus
Prime Minister Giuseppe Conte has
announced unprecedented new restrictions
affecting the areas around Milan in
Venice stiamo wrote a new name of James
ginsa Natsume Lee we are facing a
national emergency he said before
outlining has 16 million people roughly
a quarter of the population would be
quarantined for at least a month
Alitalia has since announced it has
suspended all flights to and from Milan
and Venice schools gyms museums and
clubs are also closed and anybody
wanting to leave will have to get
special permission Italians have also
been told to stay one meter away from
others and to refrain from shaking hands
or greeting others with the customary
kiss on the cheek the news leaked out
before the official announcement
creating an overnight furor that saw
many Italians try to get out before the
roads were closed but the people down
south are saying please don't come down
south because you're going to be
infecting us so it's if there's a lot of
confusion and mass hysteria at this
point
Canadian expat Margot belani says the
rules are unclear or at least they're
not being followed everywhere that it's
gone this far speaks to Italy's
desperation to contain the virus but it
remains to be seen if such dramatic
measures can be enforced microlight
Global News Toronto the outbreak is
having an impact on major sporting
events Italy's top soccer league acedia
will hold an emergency summit on Tuesday
to determine whether or not to suspend
all matches no fans have been attending
and this month's Formula One Grand Prix
in Bahrain will happen behind closed
doors without spectators trackside due
to the outbreak and in Japan there were
no fans of the country's famed
springtime sumo tournament where
wrestlers were face masks and there are
five months to go before the Tokyo
Olympics in China at least ten people
have died after a hotel used as a
quarantine center suddenly collapsed
71 people were initially trapped 23
people are still missing the hotel was
being used to isolate and monitor people
arriving from regions where the new
coronavirus is running rampant as köppen
19th global spread continues to grow at
a rapid pace so do the myths and
misinformation and that poses a risk to
the education that health officials are
trying to get out our Jeff's simple set
out to separate fact from fiction it's
fast become a must-have accessory these
surgical masks donning faces around the
world from the Chinese president to
puppies stores across the country have
sold out even though experts say that
when it comes to covet 19 they won't
make a difference
putting a mask on someone who's sick
makes perfect sense walking around the
city wearing a mask intermittently
there's no evidence to say that that's
gonna help you certain models like those
used by health professionals are more
effective but are difficult to use and
in short supply the US Surgeon General
tweeted seriously people stopped buying
masks if health care providers can't get
them it puts our communities at risk
health officials say your best bet is to
wash your hands with soap and water or
use sanitizer with at least 60% alcohol
but the mad dash for these masks is just
one example of kovat confusion and some
of the most pervasive myths are actually
downplaying the threat one popular
refrain is that the novel coronavirus is
no more dangerous than the seasonal flu
35,000 people on average die each year
from the flu did anyone know that 35,000
that's a lot of people the flu is a
killer but so far kovat 19 appears to be
deadlier typically the winter flu kills
about one in every thousand people it
infects but that number for the novel
coronavirus
appears to be closer to one in a hundred
the scary thing about novel coronavirus
is it seems like it's more contagious
and SARS and it's more deadly than
seasonal flu this statistician notes the
viruses reproduction number is 2.28
meaning each sick person is infecting at
least two others
that's enough to say it's quick
exponential growth but if we all start
being more careful in washing our hands
and so on it's possible that we could
reduce that it turns out dogs can get
the virus officials just confirmed a
case in Hong Kong but they don't think
canines are contagious children can
become infected too but like the
majority of all cases their symptoms are
mild meaning many are likely going
undiagnosed without extensive testing we
don't have a clear picture of how far
the spread has gone and all we really
can know for sure
is that it is a much larger number than
the official cases our best weapon
against the virus is the production of a
vaccine but that's likely to take at
least one year Geoff sample Global News
Toronto we know you have lots of
questions about this virus so send an
email to your questions at global news
dot see 8 and our Jeff simple will
consult experts to find the answers we
also have a special page dedicated
entirely to the new corona virus that's
a global news dossier / corona virus
coming up a global national whatever
happened to the Sanders political
revolution
in the race become Donald Trump's rival
this November election Bernie Sanders
looked like the man to beat just a few
weeks ago he surged in initial primaries
while spearheading a revolution to
change the US Democratic Party but then
Joe Biden made a comeback on Super
Tuesday and the Sanders movement has now
lost its momentum
miss Jackson Prosecco once a proud thorn
in the side of the party establishment
Bernie Sanders a self-described
Democratic Socialist is making a
last-ditch play to the mainstream bernie
is somebody who has the virtue of saying
exactly what he believes his latest ad
is carefully edited to suggest he has
the support of former President Barack
Obama the ad was released after Sanders
disappointing performance on Super
Tuesday and the departure of other
Democratic candidates who endorsed
Obama's former Vice President Joe Biden
what we've seen a surge is quite frankly
from middle-of-the-road
moderate middle-aged suburban voters who
who are more for Biden than they are for
Bernie
after his strong showing in Iowa and New
Hampshire Sanders he's suddenly left
with an uncertain path to the Democratic
nomination despite years of remarkably
consistent messaging and positions we
are not only taking on the corporate
establishment we're taking on the
political establishment
he hasn't grown his base since his
unsuccessful 2016 campaign in fact
support has slipped among some key
demographics even as he outpaces Biden
in fundraising but I am audibly honest
with you we have not done as well in
bringing young people across it is not
easy in a year where Democrats are
singularly focused on defeating Donald
Trump Sanders faces the reality that
voters may be more interested in playing
it safe than political revolution if
he's not the eventual nominee his
support and the support of his followers
will still be critical for the party I
think Trump's ability to have the left
divided is how he wins again with 46 46
40
percent of the electorate Sanders seems
to sense how fragile his grip on the
nomination has become in recent days he
has canceled campaign events in states
like Mississippi preferring to retreat
to the relative safety of states like
Michigan where he hopes to shore up his
base with working-class voters Jackson
prosecco Global News Washington
still ahead how a Canadian church leader
is trying to get the flock onto tik-tok
some of the world's oldest institutions
are turning to new platforms to track
members take the new kid on the block
tik-tok it's one of the fastest growing
social media platforms in the world the
app lets users create and share short
videos and it recently surpassed 1.5
billion downloads now as Brianna Carson
Smith reports Catholic leaders in
Edmonton are putting their faith in this
technology as a call to prayer from
adorable animals to recipes fashion
advice and choreographed dances tik-tok
truly offers something for every user
maybe one third of the audience will be
local locally Basin and you know that
two-thirds will be like elsewhere in the
world it's why a growing number of
organizations including Global News
[Music]
are signing up now the app can even be
found on phones in one of the most
unlikely of places the Catholic
Archdiocese of Edmonton is now spreading
the oldest message on the newest
platform social media strategist Lincoln
Howe came up with the idea
evangelization you know in different
mediums is not a new thing he started
with a short promotion for their day of
confessions and while it only has a
modest 235 views they're working I've
heard a few people come and say hey I
saw you one on that tape talk and I
thought oh goodness spreading the good
word on social media isn't unheard of
Pope Francis joins Twitter in 2012 and
has amassed more than 18 point 1 million
followers you never really know who
you're gonna reach with this right and
so you might capture somebody's
attention and say hey that's you know I
should really go in and do confession
but executing that message isn't easy a
tick-tock actually requires a way more
planning than other ones that I've done
something we discovered and then we
cross and we look up okay this is
complicated but a little trial and error
is something the Catholic Archdiocese of
Edmonton thinks even the Pope can get on
board with do you think he'd approve I
think it approved I think he would
certainly Briana Carson Smith Global
News also baby Edmonton
up next on global national celebrating
International Women's Day
there are celebrations and
demonstrations around the world to mark
International Women's Day in Montreal
hundreds turned out for a march of
diverse women they say they are
mobilizing against violence poverty and
discrimination south of the city in
Mohawk territory members of the
community gathered to celebrate the
traditional role of indigenous women as
caretakers of the land life givers title
holders of the land and was responsible
for our children our children's children
and those have yet to be born
tensions marred some celebrations in
Kyrgyzstan women were assaulted by
masked men then police detained dozens
in Pakistan demonstrations took place
despite organized rallies to counter the
March some protesters threw stones and
shoes at the women's rally thousands of
women across Spain turned out to march
against gender inequality demonstrators
paraded down Madrid's streets to the
beat of tribal drums decked out in
purple the International symbol for
women and that is global national for
this Sunday I'm Robin Gill we leave you
tonight with more images from
International Women's Day from around
the world thank you for watching and
good night
[Music]